my buddy Chris Sims little fuse on a
radio appearance in Dallas earlier this
week and there's a lot of talk now about
what's going on with dak Prescott in the
cowboys and what dak wants and what the
Cowboys want to paint and look here's
I'm gonna put it all in a nutshell and I
wrote the item at pft yesterday at a
time when it you know there's reports
and counter reports and and this is
right and this is wrong and whatever
look none of it matters right now none
of it matters stephen jones the cowboys
CEO told me two weeks ago july 15 is the
deadline nobody is moving anywhere close
to their bottom-line position until we
get toward July 15 anything now is just
talk when we get and really here's
what's gonna happen Memorial Day this
weekend Independence Day coming up early
July the 4th I think it is I don't know
I may be misremembering but after that
that's what I'm kidding that's when the
window opens on getting this deal done
after the 4th of July everyone will
focus on getting the dak Prescott deal
done and that's when people start moving
toward their bottom line and here's the
thing to keep in mind big cat it's not
about what the quarterback market is
it's not about what dak Prescott is
worth it's not about what anyone else is
making or what anyone else will be
making here's what it comes down to dak
Prescott has right now the ability to
make 31.4 million this year thirty seven
point six eight million next year under
the rules of the franchise tag and then
for 2022 it's the Kirk Cousins dilemma
54 million is what the Cowboys would
have to offer him to tag him again or 45
million if they use the transition tag
which is the right to match but no
compensation or you let him walk away
that's what his rights are right now
he's got the Kirk Cousins with much more
money at play than cousins had cousins
had 20 and 24 Prescott has 31 and 37 and
the promise of 54 or 45 what does it
take to get him to trade that in that's
what it is it's like that's his car his
car is this 69 million dollar machine
plus the chance to become a free agent
in two years what will it take for the
Cowboys to get him to say I'll sign your
contract instead of doing what I have
the
right to do and that means it's gonna be
a crapload at almost at a different
worth and crapload of money for him to
sign away his rights under the franchise
tag it's that simple it's going to be a
gigantic contract because otherwise he
just goes year-to-year okay Mike but
here's my only question with this entire
negotiation don't you think that the
Cowboys having it go on this long and
again you said that there's going to be
a deadline of July 15 so it hasn't
gotten all the way to the end but the
fact that we're still talking about Jack
Prescott not having a new deal says
everything about what the Cowboys think
about dak Prescott and in that I mean
he's a good quarterback but he's not if
this was Patrick McCombs the deal would
have been done it's not the no-doubter
guy it's not the guy that says whatever
you want
we will pay because you are a
quarterback for the next decade and I
think that's just the interesting aspect
here where they could sign him tomorrow
but I still will tell I was still in the
back of my head say the Cowboys and dak
Prescott couldn't get a deal done right
away which kind of tells me what they
think about dak Prescott see I disagree
with you I think what happened was when
the window opened on a second contract
for dak Prescott after the conclusion of
the 2018 regular season third season for
any player regular season ends that's
when you can sign him to a new contract
even if you're in the playoffs you can
sign him that week before the first
playoff game to a new contract and
that's what the Cowboys should have done
make him an offer he can't refuse then
because and to what they always thought
was he's eventually gonna he's a venture
no no they thought he'll eventually come
around and he'll take a team friendly
deal and we'll just wait and he'll take
a team friendly deal what they didn't
count on is dak Prescott working with
his agents at CAA and looking at this as
a business proposition and saying wait a
minute wait a minute the longer I wait
and the more games that I get through
without a serious injury the injury risk
goes to them the injury risk leaves me
so once he gets through that full fourth
year of his contract and now he's he's
got no contract he's got 30 1.4 million
this year the guy made two million last
year 31 point four million for one year
of football he gets through this season
healthy it's another 37 million so this
isn't
about now oh well Russell Wilson's
making 35 and Aaron Rodgers making 32 no
this is about dak Prescott's gonna make
69 point oh eight million over the next
two years
if he goes year-to-year the Cowboys have
to offer him something that gets him to
say I'll give up my ability to make 69
million over two years by waiting for
him to do a team friendly deal they have
backed themselves into a corner where he
can dictate the terms now and the only
way they're gonna get him signed is to
give him something that gets him to say
okay fine I'll give up 69 million plus a
chance to become a free agent in 2022
but that's still my point i I think dak
Prescott is in some circles people are
saying dak Prescott should you know and
the whole highest-paid quarterback thing
is kind of silly because it's a lot of
times it's whoever's up next but my
point still remains dak Prescott is not
a no-doubter here's here's a blank check
whatever you want we will sign it and it
hasn't been for the last two years and
that's my point is that it kind of
lingers in the back of my head saying
dak Prescott is a good quarterback but
if he were a no-doubter
franchise super bowl-winning quarterback
type of guy this would have been done a
long time ago and even though it still
would have been done like this year even
if he didn't do it two years ago then
why did they franchise tag then why did
they apply a franchise tag and why did
Steven Jones tell me two weeks ago they
will absolutely not rescind the
franchise tag if they don't get a deal
done by July 15 let her ask just walk
away but you don't agree that there's if
that Prescott was the guy that were 'td
like if he was patch Chrome's there will
not be this with Patrick Holmes no
chance timeout timeout
watch and learn big cat I'm gonna give
you an education on how the NFL actually
works financially Fred there's two
levels of the franchise tag they chose
the highest possible level they could
have gone the base franchise tag of
about 26 million and the math that I was
talking about earlier
if you're starting at 26 versus 31.4 the
numbers change dramatically right they
could have done they could have said
well you know what we're not sure about
dak but if there's somebody else out
there that really wants to pay him a
hell of a lot more money than we will
we'll take two first-round picks as
compensation for dad
prescott under the rules of the base
non-exclusive franchise tag they went
exclusive they went high end they went
Cadillac so they may not think he's a
Cadillac but they've activated the
Cadillac franchise tag that's what I
can't reconcile I don't disagree with
you this isn't Patrick mahomes this
isn't a guy who's the best quarterback
in the NFL he's probably not even in the
top three or four right now maybe not
the top five but when they activate the
highest level franchise tag they're
stepping into that mess and now now
they're stuck now they're stuck unless
they say after July 15 if we don't do a
long-term deal where we're sending the
franchise tag that's their only play at
this point and Stephen Jones has already
told me they will absolutely not do that
so what happens with the Cadillac
franchise tag if someone wants to trade
for him so what's the difference why
would they what's the benefit of doing
the the pricier franchise tag because he
never gets out he can't go you it's
never an issue of another team trying to
sign him see I have no idea what the
open market would bear for dak Prescott
if that Prescott to become an
unrestricted free agent in March of this
year
with Tom Brady and Philip Rivers in Drew
Brees technically a free agent all the
other guys who were around what would
someone have paid him would someone have
given him 35 36 37 million a year I
don't think I'm right and I'll tell you
what and the fact that they're
voluntarily giving up their nuclear
option is stunning to me because big cat
if this is that let's let's say it would
play out this way July 15 comes and goes
there's no long-term deal done that
means they can't do anything more than a
one-year deal this year and and then
that Prescott under the rules of the tag
exercises his prerogative to stay away
from training camp in the preseason like
Le'Veon Bell did in 2017 with the
Steelers if the Cowboys removed the
franchise tag from dak Prescott at any
point after July 15 he'll if they would
do it now what the hell's he getting
from someone else is someone else gonna
give him 30 million a year much less 35
million here he'll know everybody's got
their quarterbacks if they would remove
that franchise tag from him right now
and say we're gonna go sign Cam Newton
he would be screwed and that's why I was
amazed two weeks ago when Steven Jones
said up we're just not we're not we're
not gonna we're not gonna
ever rescind the franchise tag they need
to make him think that they would that's
the only way to get him to bargain away
from his I'll just take my 69 million
over the next two years because they're
responsibly not so fast you may not get
31.4 million this year because we may
rescind the tender okay you helped me a
little there my point still stands that
he's obviously not worth the whatever
you want give it to him money in that
type of quarterback but I appreciate you
teaching me about this this is actually
similar to like the plot of Good Will
Hunting except you're the caterer who's
teaching the the diner something nice
and new about math because you get your
caterers shirt on and that is a I'm
saying that because you said let me
teach you something so that was a
tit-for-tat that's what they say let me
just say this if if you're if you're
gonna make a reference to a movie from
the early 1990s my only response to you
is this okay boomer next up by Tom Brady
could be more like Vince Lombardi than
Michael Jordan what's more likely as
next right here on pro football's buck
live
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports